[Music]
well the big topic everybody's mine
today is on hurricane sandy you know
fortunately fortunately it's a the worst
is over yes a storm has passed and but
it's all over the news and now people
are discussing the cause the senior
editor of the Scientific American says
that hurricane sandy was partly caused
by global warming yeah meanwhile
meanwhile Fox News says it was caused by
two men kissing in Central Park
and we know who they are you know it's
weird the hurricane took a lot of
attention away from the World Series you
guys jazzed about that at all San
Francisco this afternoon this afternoon
in honor of the World Series Taco Bell
gave out free Doritos Locos Tacos in San
Francisco which means now the West Coast
could be hit with an explosive flood
[Applause]
yeah oh I'm quite proud of myself yeah
we do have a presidential campaign to
think about in an interview former
Florida Governor Jeb Bush said that
during the campaign President Obama's
been quote acting like a ten-year-old
yeah Jeb's exact quote was Obama's
acting like a real George W Bush a
[Music]
political executive in charge of Apple
maps has been let go he was fired
yesterday but he still can't find his
way out of the building
[Applause]
seven years of mime school right there
hey this is exciting it was announced
today that there will be a new Star Wars
movie in 2015 luckily by then Harrison
Ford will be old enough to play Yoda
Harrison Ford I am this is a big story
though it broke just a couple hours ago
George Lucas has sold his film company
and he said it's time to pass Star Wars
on to a new generation of filmmakers
yeah unfortunately the company he sold
it to was hustler video Luke who's your
daddy what'd I say unfortunately I would
watch those movies get Larry Flynt in
there that'd be great the best of porn
with great special effects you're oh
you're not interesting
you're better than me some controversy
in the NBA the Minnesota Timberwolves
are being accused of having too many
white players
some say it's a ploy to appeal to a
mostly white fanbase yeah the owner
claims it's not a ploy to win fans it's
a ploy to lose games thank you in
Australia you're gonna like this in
Australia I'm not asking you I'm telling
you you're gonna repeat this to your
grandchildren one day that's how good
this corker is in Australia a couples
getting married inside an Ikea store
yeah which means their marriage will
likely fall apart in two years
[Applause]
got an award for that joke
I this interesting scientists are
testing a new product that's being
referred to as viagra for women the new
product is called white wine
[Applause]
I am
[Music]